[Musique]
ouais c'est moi, je m'appelle Ferdinand, c'est comme très
grand, tu es énorme, plus de moi pour aimer
très fort, tu es prêt à mettre ces ailes
au travail, regarde oh
non, tu as tiré sur Maria au soleil, désolé,
la famille Pepper était le bon garçon, mais si
le monde voit Ferdinand est une chose un
combattant Je suis ici descendu en couple mes
chasses pour mes instruments nous sommes mes bras
prochain test et par les canards non je vais réussir
merci les gars allez-y je sais exactement
ce que ressent Ferdinand allons-y
et donnons  c'est à 110% en fait je vais
transmettre la violence que
tu es enfin prêt à combattre allez je
ne suis PAS un garçon combattant le film envoie un
message qui résonne très fort
en moi
ne juge pas un taureau à sa couverture il y a des
endroits  là-bas où vous ne vous faites pas
bousculer parce que vous êtes vous-même, tête
pour un et monopolise pour tout le monde
[Musique]
des créateurs de Ice Age et Wheel
Je sors de cet endroit, pouvez-vous
juste essayer d'être un peu plus silencieux le
porte vers la liberté, faites exactement ce que nous
faisons exactement comme vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous avons une nouvelle tradition Je suis désolé,
c'est de ma faute si nous n'avons pas de
tradition familiale, faire du porte-à-porte à la recherche de
famille  traditions nous fabriquons des cannes de bonbon
ensemble, tu
coupes un arbre en sucre et ensuite tu habilles ses
cours avec des bougies
[Musique] [Musique]
[Musique]
rien de tel que de répondre à tes appels de temps
en temps tu sais c'est
dégueulasse ça m'a traversé
[Musique  ]
vous,
Roméo et Juliette, déménagez dans un tout
nouveau jardin, tout est clair,
pas tout à fait parfait, mais c'est le nôtre, pensez à
toutes les aventures que nous allons avoir, oh
mec Katie, c'est juste, as-tu fini une
minute, le quiz que les
humains arrivent pose à tous ceux qu'ils étaient
censés vivre  heureux pour toujours, mais
quand leur monde est en danger,
Julia les gnomes lancent une tasse, il n'y en a qu'une
seule à appeler et Sherlock sait que le
protecteur juré du jardin sait que
tu veux dire, à l'exception de celle que tu viens
littéralement de briser
[Musique]
ces pièces sont en terrible danger de
mort.  directeur de Kung Fu Panda
personne ne peut entendre ça mais ils vont
s'écraser ou demain soir ou une
aventure nous devons traverser cette
rivière tu auras besoin d'un navire pas de merde
Sherlock
tu as une grande
lynnie inconnue notre prochaine  l'indice est dans le parc, obtenez
rapidement votre chemin, suivez la
ligne bleue au sol jusqu'à ce que vous trouviez les
Suns rouges géants MacAvoy et nous avons bloqué
Attila Jeff pour Mary J Blige et Johnny
Depp avec la musique originale d'Elton John
et Bernie Taupin,
ils doivent y aller  sous couverture, allons en
avant,
j'ai dit à la maison, pardonne-moi, je n'avais jamais été
l'arrière d'un écureuil avant que
Sherlock sache que ce n'est pas comme ça qu'un écureuil
six est derrière mankini, peux-tu
démontrer que tu vois ce que je fais,
tu vois oui, tu es  agissant comme un arrière-
train
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [Musique] [
Musique]
Oh, généreuses, honnêtes, pures
créatures gracieuses, notre espace naturel de lapin
devrait être capable de suivre, savez-vous
ce qui n'aurait jamais fonctionné
exactement sans pantalon, vous devez être Peter
Rabbit  ouais c'est vrai attends tu n'as pas
essayé de me manger montre-moi tes dents tu
aimes un go block c'était toi comment vas-tu
si bon de te voir
je ne pense pas à une chose qui pourrait
arrêter notre plaisir
tu viens  bonjour par ici
[Musique]
nouveau voisin, je vais lui expliquer,
nous partagerons nos terres par ici bonjour, je m'appelle
Bea, ces portes sont incroyablement
solides, j'ai juste besoin de garder la faune à l'écart,
tu plaisantes, c'est
vrai, oui  ce sont des anges, c'est leur
place, ok, donc il s'est trompé, il n'y a
qu'un seul moyen de s'en sortir, il peut essayer,
tu sais qu'ils ont posé des pièges dans mon lit,
c'est un lapin, il ne ferait de mal à personne, j'ai
un problème de vermine, un crayon électrique.
courrier papier non mme.  tiggy-winkle arrête de
détourner le regard nous ne pouvons pas abandonner c'est notre maison
tu es à moi ribbit
qu'est-ce qui se passe mais attends - les garçons étant
seuls
rien ne pourrait me rendre plus heureux je nous ai mis
dans ce bateau je vais arranger ça
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que ma souris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez alors combien d'entre nous avez-vous
vous
[Musique]
[Musique] [Musique] [Musique] [Musique
]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
[Musique]
toi